hola a todos aquí tengo la gráfica de
una función de dos variables y quisiera
hablar de cómo podríamos interpretar la
derivada parcial de esta función
específicamente tengo la función f de x
xi y estamos viendo su gráfica fx
igual a x cuadrada por ye más el seno de
ella y la pregunta es si tomamos la
derivada parcial de esta función digamos
la derivada parcial de f con respecto a
x aunque digamos que quiero hacer esto
en menos 11 muy bien así que estamos
viendo a la derivada parcial en este
punto específico como interpretamos esto
en toda la gráfica primero consideremos
donde se encuentra el punto menos 11 muy
bien y si aquí lo vemos entonces aquí
tenemos el eje x el eje i y el punto
menos 11 se encuentra justo ahí así que
el menos uno digamos nos movemos uno
hacia arriba verdad cuando estamos
hablando de derivadas parciales con
respecto de x estamos pretendiendo que
ya es constante así que de hecho vamos a
tratar de evaluar esto
cuando hacemos esto digamos x cuadradas
se ve como nuestra variable verdad y que
simplemente serían una constante seno de
jett también sería una constante así que
la derivada parcial con respecto de x
verdad sería 2x porque que ya es como
una constante y luego la derivada de una
constante de cero verdad así que estamos
evaluando todo esto en x igual a menos 1
y es igual a 1 verdad así que cuando
cuando introducimos estos valores verdad
sería 2 x menos uno por uno que es menos
2 aquí y qué significa esto bueno cuando
evaluamos quizás estamos pensando que
tenemos un pequeño cambio en la
dirección de x verdad y eso nos resulta
en un cambio en f verdad qué significa
esto para la gráfica bueno primero
tratamos aie constante y básicamente es
digamos cortar toda la gráfica con un
plano que representa a un valor
constante de iu así que si tenemos aquí
el eje y y el plano que lo corta
perpendicular
esto representa a un
y constante para allá y este representa
al valor de igual a uno verdad ahora
bien si imaginamos que estamos
desplazando este plano digamos hacia
adelante y hacia ella hacia atrás esto
representaría distintos valores fijos
para iu pero digamos esto pensándolo
para una derivada parcial general verdad
y podríamos imaginar que en realidad por
ejemplo aquí cuando hoy es igual a 1
podríamos cortar la gráfica en ese punto
y dibujar una línea roja y esta curva
roja básicamente son todos los puntos
que se encuentran en la gráfica en donde
ya es igual a 1 así que voy a remarcar
esto esto es cuando ya es igual a 1
entonces cuando nos fijamos en esto de
hecho podemos interpretar la derivada
parcial como una pendiente porque
justamente nos estamos fijando en el
punto de aquí y nos preguntamos cómo es
que la función cambia cuando nos movemos
en la dirección x así que el cálculo de
una variable con el cual quizás ya estás
familiarizado verdad cuando pensamos en
esto en realidad pensamos como la
pendiente de una línea verdad y para
hacer un poquito más
concretos podría decir que al iniciar
aquí consideramos una pequeña desviación
por aquí un pequeño paso verdad lo estoy
dibujando quizás muy grande pero puedes
imaginar que realmente es un paso muy
muy muy pequeño verdad una de equis y
entonces medimos la distancia que nos
genera con la función aquí verdad el
cambio en el valor de nuestra función y
dije de equis pero quizás debería decir
parcial de equis verdad o parcial de f y
si éste si esta desviación es muy
pequeña o lo vamos haciendo cada vez más
y más y más pequeño este cambio de aquí
en realidad va a corresponder con lo que
lo que corresponde a la línea tangente
es decir a la pendiente de dicha línea
verdad es tenemos el cociente entre el
cambio horizontal y el cambio vertical
verdad y si nos fijamos en el valor en
la línea verdad parece que tiene una
pendiente negativa es más o menos de
menos 2 y podría de hecho es esto tiene
sentido verdad que hayamos obtenido
menos 2 verdad y lo estamos viendo pero
ahora hagamos lo siguiente tenemos la
derivada parcial con respecto a y vamos
a borrar lo que teníamos anteriormente y
ahora vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con
la gráfica muy bien vamos a quitar todo
esto ya no vamos a estar cortando con
respecto a y ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es un corte con un valor constante de x
así que si tenemos aquí el eje x este
plano corresponde a un valor constante
de x igual a menos 1 y podríamos cortar
a la gráfica aquí ok si la cortamos
entonces nuevamente dibujamos nuestra
línea roja que representa la curva en
este en este lugar verdad representa el
valor de x igual a menos 1 son todos los
puntos en la gráfica en donde x es igual
a menos 1 y ahora tomamos la derivada
parcial y vamos a interpretarlo como un
corte verdad
digamos va a ser la pendiente de esta
curva resultante verdad la pendiente de
la recta tangente verdad y esto termina
viéndose así aquí tenemos nuestra línea
azul verdad
vamos ahora a evaluar la derivada
parcial de f con respecto de sí así que
vámonos aquí usemos otro color
tenemos la parcial de f con respecto de
y verdad y entonces tendríamos x
cuadrada porque verdad si derivamos
verdad considerando x cuadrada como una
constante tendríamos simplemente que la
derivada de ye que es nuestra variable
verdad es 1 verdad y eso simplemente nos
da x cuadrada y ahora por ejemplo por
acá tenemos el seno de la derivada de de
esto con respecto al escocés no de y muy
bien y si de hecho quisiéramos evaluar
esto en nuestro punto menos 11 entonces
tendríamos aquí menos 1 al cuadrado que
es uno más
el coseno de uno y en realidad no sé
cuánto vale el coseno de uno pero bueno
eso lo sé que es algo ligeramente
positivo verdad y el último resultado
que vemos aquí a final de cuentas es que
va a ser
uno más otra cosa verdad que es positivo
y en realidad no sabemos cuánto es pero
bueno es algo positivo verdad y eso
tiene sentido porque cuando nos fijamos
en la pendiente de aquí es un poquito
mayor que uno no sabemos exactamente
cuánto pero es mayor que 1 así que a
menudo vas a escuchar que algunas
personas hablan de tomar derivadas
parciales como las pendientes de los
cortes de una gráfica lo cual es
bastante bueno si nos fijamos en una
función que tiene una entrada de dos
dimensiones y una salida de una
dimensión en realidad podríamos pensar
en su gráfica y en otros contextos
quizás este no es el caso
quizás digamos tenemos una salida
multidimensional de lo cual vamos a
hablar más adelante en particular de
cómo se ven sus derivadas parciales o
también podríamos tener algo que tiene
no se sientas de entradas verdad y
ciertamente no podemos visualizar la
gráfica pero la idea general es bueno
pensar qué pasaría si damos un paso muy
muy pequeño en una dirección así que
aquí lo que estamos haciendo es reto
el contexto de la gráfica verdad nos
fijamos en un punto por aquí
y decimos damos un pequeño paso en la
dirección llego en la dirección x y eso
los vamos a llamar derivadas parciales
respecto de yo respecto de x verdad y
eso hace algún cambio en nuestra función
ya eso es a lo que vamos a llamar
parcial de la función verdad la derivada
parcial y puedes imaginar que esto se
está haciendo muy muy muy pequeño como
resultado del cambio verdad y al final
lo que tenemos es una proporción verdad
de cómo cambia la función dividido entre
lo que avanzamos en una dirección verdad
y esa es una pendiente de una línea
verdad que digamos para pasos
infinitamente pequeños sería una línea
tangente así que esta es una forma de
interpretar esa proporción verdad el
cambio en la salida que corresponde a un
pequeño una pequeña desviación en la
entrada ya más adelante hablaremos de
otras formas en que podemos hacer esto
así que yo creo que pensar en gráficas
es muy útil pero cuando digamos nos
movemos hacia otros contextos en
realidad ya no es muy muy conveniente
verdad
me gusta pensar en las gráficas porque
es bueno saber estas cosas pero no son
la única forma de entenderlas y no
quiero que te ates completamente a la
idea de las gráficas incluso cuando
puedan ser muy útiles en el contexto de
dos variables de entrada y una variable
de salida nos vemos en el próximo vídeo